>>> CANADIANS ARE HEADING TO THE
POLLS TODAY.
PRIME MINISTER JUSTIN TRUDEAU'S
DECISION TO CALL A SNAP ELECTION
SEVERAL WEEKS AGO COULD
BACKFIRE.
HE IS FACING A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE FROM THE CONSERVATIVE.
AND TRUDEAU IS HOPING TO USE HIS
HANDLING OF THE PANDEMIC AND
COVID-19 VACCINE ROLLOUT TO HELP
HIM WIN.
BUT MANY SEE HIS MOVE AS
OPPORTUNISTIC GIVEN THAT CANADA
IS IN A FOURTH WAVE OF COVID
INFECTIONS.
PAULA NEWTON IS JOINING US LIVE
FROM MONTREAL.
WHAT IS THE MOOD ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS PEOPLE GO OUT TO VOTE
TODAY?
>> Reporter: IT IS CRANKY,
BECKY.
I WON'T LIE.
LOOK, IT IS A BEAUTIFUL DAY, ONE
OF THE LAST DAYS OF SUMMER HERE.
CANADIANS JUST TRYING TO GET A
BREATHER FROM THIS PANDEMIC.
AND AS YOU MENTIONED, THIS IS A
FOURTH WAVE.
WHILE IT MAY NOT BE AS BRUISING
HERE AS IT IS ON THE WEST COAST,
ON THE WEST COAST MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS ARE ASKING THAT
THE ARMY BE CALLED IN IN
ALBERTA.
IN THAT CONTEXT, JUSTIN TRUDEAU
LOOKED AT THE POLLS AND THOUGHT
THAT I COULD ACTUALLY PERHAPS
HERE TAKE CONTROL OF PARLIAMENT
IN CANADA, AND HE CALLED IN AN
ELECTION.
AND THE ELECTION LASTED ONLY
FIVE WEEKS.
BUT THIS HAS REALLY TURNED IN TO
QUITE A GAMBLE FOR JUSTIN
TRUDEAU AND HE COULD STILL LSE
HIS JOB.
>> Reporter: A SNAP ELECTION
SEEMED A RUDE INTRUSION.
IT IS THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC,
NOT EVEN TWO YEARS SINCE THE
LAST ONE, AND IT WAS TOUGH TO
DODGE.
ESPECIALLY THIS CAMPAIGN.
IT WAS UGLY.
THIS THE TOKEN MOMENT.
PROTESTORS MANY OPPOSING
VACCINES THREW GRAVEL AT JUSTIN
TRUDEAU AND STALKED HIS
CAMPAIGN.
HIS RIVALS HAVE HIT HIM
RHETORICALLY CALLING HIMSELFISH
AND CALLING A SNAP ELECTION IN
MID AUGUST TRYING TO CAPITALIZE
ON GOOD POLL NUMBERS.
AT FIRST THE FAVORABLE POLLS
COLLAPSED FOR TRUDEAU.
FOR A FEW WEEKS HE EVEN TRAILED
O'TOOLE WHO ACCUSED HIM OF
ATTEMPTING A POWER GRAB.
>> WE'RE ACTUALLY IN THE MIDDLE
OF AN UNNECESSARY $600 MILLION
PANDEMIC ELECTION CALLED BY MR.
TRUDEAU FOR NO OTHER REASON THAN
HIMSELF.
>> Reporter: THE ANGRY, LOUD
ANTI-VACCINE CHANTS PUT THE
PANDEMIC SQUARELY IN VOTER
SIGHTS.
>> WE'LL TRUST SCIENCE, WE'LL
TRUST THE EXPERTS, WE'LL MAKE
SURE ANYONE ON A PLANE OR TRAIN
IS VACCINATED.
>> Reporter: AND AN HOUR FROM
MONTREAL, THIS IS A DISTRICT
THAT HAS VOTED FOR THREE
DIFFERENT PARTIES IN THE LAST
DECADE.
ORGANIC FARMER ISABELLE WAS
LOOKING ON WITH SHEAR
EXHAUSTION.
SHE LIKE SO MANY CANADIANS
WANTED TO HEAR MORE ABOUT
ENDURING ISSUES LIKE CLIMATE
CHANGE.
>> I WON'T BE GOING ON WHAT THIS
LITTLE EVENT ON THE RIGHT OR
THIS LITTLE EVENT ON THE LEFT,
YOU KNOW, THAT BOTHERED ME OR
THAT MADE A BIG THING ON THE
NEWS, YOU KNOW.
TO ME THAT IS NOT THE BIG
PICTURE OF IT.
>> Reporter: BUT TIME AND AGAIN
THE ELECTION PIVOTED BACK TO THE
PANDEMIC IN DIVISIVE WAYS.
THE LOCAL NEW DEMOCRATIC PARTY
CANDIDATE SAYS THE PEOPLES PARTY
IMPORTED A BRAND OF
DISINFORMATION.
>> NOT REALLY BEING IN TRUTH,
SORRY TO SAY, THAT TRUMP DIDN'T
HELP ON THAT ISSUE.
>> Reporter: A SHORT DRIVE AWAY
THE PEOPLES PARTY CANDIDATE IS
PRESSING HER POINTS TO VOTERS
AND SHE SAYS THEY ARE LISTENING.
>> BECAUSE WE GIVE THEM FREEDOM
OF CHOICE.
WE BELIEVE IN A CHOICE AS
OPPOSED TO FORCED VACCINATION.
>> Reporter: THIS IS STILL A
TIGHT RACE WITH TRUDEAU FAVORED
TO WIN BUT PERHAPS WITH NO MORE
POLITICAL POWER THAN HE STARTED
WITH.
THE CAMPAIGN MAY NOT CHANGE
CANADA'S LEADER OR EVEN ITS
PARLIAMENT, BUT IT HAS ALREADY
LEFT ITS MARK ON THE VERY
CHARACTER OF POLITICS HERE.
IT SURE HAS, AND IN A LOT OF
WAYS PEOPLE DID NOT EXPECT.
I WILL TALK TO YOU AGAIN ABOUT
TURNOUT.
REMEMBER, THIS IS A PANDEMIC
CAMPAIGN.
THERE ARE ALREADY LONG LINEUPS
AT SOME POLLING STATIONS AN I
DON'T THIS COUNTRY.
GOT KEEP THE SOCIAL DISTANCING,
FEWER WORKERS AT THE POLLS.
IT WILL BE AN INTERESTING DAY
AND NIGHT HERE.
>> AND I'M JUST INTERESTING TO
PURSUE THIS IDEA THAT THERE ARE
NOW CONCERNS THIS ELECTION COULD
BRING ABOUT MORE POLARIZATION.
I MEAN, THE CHARGES ARE THAT
TRUDEAU HAS BROUGHT THIS ON
HIMSELF.
JUST LET'S FOCUS FOR A MOMENT ON
THIS IDEA OF MORE POLARIZATION.
HOW MIGHT THAT MANIFEST ITSELF
AND HOW DAMAGING MIGHT THAT BE
AT THIS POINT?
>> Reporter: WE COULD END UP
WITH QUITE A SCRAMBLE.
REMEMBER THIS IS A PARLIAMENTARY
SYSTEM, THERE ARE NO LESS THAN
SIX PARTIES RUNNING.
AND THE TRUDEAU GOVERNMENT IS
PROPPED UP BY THE NEW DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND THEIR LEADER.
THAT COULD STILL BE THE WAY IT
TURNS OUT TONIGHT.
BUT IF THERE IS NOT ONE PARTY
THAT CAN EFFECTIVELY FORM A
MINORITY GOVERNMENT, YOU MIGHT
BE ABLE TO COBBLE TOGETHER A
GOVERNMENT BUT IT IS STILL A BIG
RISK.
IN THE MEDAL OF ALL THAT, PUT
THIS ATTEND WHICH IS REALLY
SHOWN A LIGHT AND TAKEN REALLY
THE VENEER OFF ANY KIND OF UNITY
WITH PEOPLE POLARIZING AROUND
THE ISSUE OF THE PANDEMIC.
AND IT IS STARTLING TO CANADIANS
IN A WAY THAT MANY DID NOT WANT
TO HEAR.
AGAIN, MORE RHETORIC.
AND YOU SAW EVEN THOUGH IT WAS
TOKEN GRAVEL, NO ONE WAS HURT IN
THAT EVENT, CERTAINLY DIFFERENT
FOR CANADA AND SOMETHING MANY
PEOPLE WILL KEEP